[Music]
welcome to the data science hangout if
you're joining for the first time it's
great to meet you
i'm rachel i'm the host of the hangout
if this is your first hangout
this is an open space for the whole data
science community to connect and chat
about data science leadership
questions you're facing what's going on
in the world of data science
and so we want this to be a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
so there's three ways you can ask
questions
you can always jump in live and just
raise your hand on zoom that seems to be
the easiest
way
you could also put questions in the zoom
chat
and just put a little star there if you
want me to ask the question
out loud if you're maybe like in a
coffee shop or something
and then we also have a slido link where
you can ask anonymous questions
and so tyler or rob will share that
in just a second here
just want to reiterate we love to hear
from everyone no matter your level of
experience to or or the industry that
you work in
but i'm so happy to be joined by my
co-host for today joe gibson
joe is a senior project director at de
beaumont foundation
and former director of epidemiology at
marion county public health department
and joe i'd love to have you jump in
here and introduce yourself and maybe
share a little bit about your role and
the foundation
sure um
so i've been at de beaumont just since
december so it's not that long we're
working on a really interesting project
to
develop
health centered local data ecosystems
that already exist all over the place i
mean there's already health data at any
location that gets used by different
people for different purposes
but try to develop those
so that they're more focused on equity
and anti-racism
with a lot of community engagement to
guide the use of that data especially
engagement by
communities are generally marginalized
so try to try to focus that data toward
identifying structural racism and
addressing issues of structural racism
to bring more bring the data more to
bear on those issues
so anyway
uh that's what i'm doing doing with the
beaumont and i'm just kind of
informatics advisors as well there but
uh i've spent 18 years as indianapolis's
uh epidemiology
program director within the marion
county public health department and been
very involved nationally in trying to
improve public health informatics
essentially
a lot of partnership with
healthcare informatics we've got the
regenstrip institute here in
indianapolis which is a
real leader in terms of clinical
informatics
thanks joe and thanks for all that
you're doing in this space too
i know i actually was introduced uh to
you by jennifer who comes to the hangout
quite a bit and she
let me know how you had grown the team
from one to 17 epidemiologists
back when you worked together
at the public health department and love
to just
kind of hear a little bit about how you
did that and
your journey in doing so
um and a lot of the credit goes to our
director she really values data
um and i came in you know i'm just a
data geek there were four people in the
group
um
and i just started organizing our data
sets into a central area
um trying to link data together and
trying to amass more data and organize
it so we could be very responsive to any
sort of data requests that came through
from the director from our all our
community partners all the all the
in public health public health only
works for partnerships so there's all
sorts of people in the community are
concerned with health and
we're trying to get grants to improve
health clinics um you know a hunger
network all sorts of groups like that
so we tried to set up systems so we
could really quickly respond to their
needs and so we were able to use mainly
sas and then we got into r to organize
the data sets and present the data out
to the community and then partner with a
lot of other local sort of data oriented
organizations we could give them data
and they could create interfaces to it
as well
um
just over time just by being valuable by
pulling in more grants
the
group slowly grew i was there 18 years
so
the growth from about four to about 20
was over 18 years
about half of that was through grants
and about half of that was through
general fund from the health department
because
we were valuable
that's awesome
what was that process like of getting
people on board to use sas and and then
r
it was it was interesting there it was
it's always so hard to when you hire
somebody to really have a good
assessment of their skills and we were
constantly trying to figure out how to
assess skills as we hired people um
you know we would have
earth you know at first it was around
sas and so we had sort of this question
about people's experience and skills and
sas and we'd ask them very specific to
do specific tasks around sas uh
and i remember somebody who did really
well in the quiz but turned out not to
just sort of have a mind
for
doing the programming and other folks
who didn't especially do well on those
quizzes and just
grocked to the the program and were able
to do amazing things so
never really cracked that nut um
but always
had a lot of support within the group so
we try to create a really open
environment where people are expected to
ask for help from other people um that
nobody was
working on your own was not a good thing
um
we had to balance some people just
wanted to sort of learning by
discovering themselves but i really
tried to push people to ask questions
and
we set up systems where everybody's code
got reviewed by somebody else in the
group
which was
in part it was a quality check but more
it probably provided value by helping
people see different approaches to
coding so somebody took one approach and
somebody else comes in they go you know
i'm learning something from your code or
they're looking at code that
could be improved and they're teaching
somebody how to improve it so
just a a validation process we had for
any uh any work products being produced
the code had to be
audited we call it a code audit by
somebody else
that's been a that was a really good
learning
tool within the group to bring people
along in their programming
and then we tried to have a environment
where people could just go like
encourage people to innovate and take
chances and
create things and
it's you know it was okay to make
mistakes but it wasn't okay not to try
things
it sounds like a great culture on the
team just being able to go ask everyone
questions too and i wonder how that
differs with
being
in person and being able to work
together versus now like working
virtually too or or work some people in
different locations
there are good good and bad things about
it but net we i think we actually were
more effective when we went virtual we
used uh we use webex teams for
you know chat but you know everybody's
got some sort of chat tool um
and that actually increased a lot of the
interactions that we had with people
because it was so easy to quickly send a
message to somebody else about something
so net
was kind of a good thing there's still a
lot of challenges in sort of
establishing the relationships
especially when you hire new people
and it was all virtual to really
make somebody feel like they're part of
the team
um you know we couldn't have lunches
together which was always the highlight
of
the day
yeah
sometimes i struggle with knowing like
if it's when it's okay to ask people
questions like virtually like through
slack because i feel like i'm just like
i don't know
interrupting people which i am but or
knowing what's the best way to do that
too
yeah we had a couple discussions in our
staff meetings around that what what
will be our protocol what's acceptable
what's not acceptable to try to
encourage
a reasonable amount of communication
without people feeling that imposed upon
so we said we said some standards there
i see there's an anonymous question um
that came in that says did you have to
deal with any mistrust of open source
tools when switching from sas to r
um
not really
we we had a lot of autonomy in terms of
what tools we decided to use
so
yeah i t really didn't challenge that
much
so i i would say no
i might dig into this a bit deeper
because i was just on a
call yesterday with three people who
were having struggles with convincing it
or just like bringing
open source tools to i.t
um
how did you introduce it to them
oh we just asked for it i mean but this
was this is only we only got heavily
into our
um
we got very heavily into r during the
covid pandemic just early on in that
because the the
visualization interface was just a lot
easier for us to work with in sas and to
expand upon
um
but we'd started dabbling in our just
just like five or seven years ago
um and by that point rit group which is
a great great group really
a lot of forward-thinking people and
that was pretty open already to open
source
you know
so it wasn't there really wasn't a lot
of question they just we said this is
something we need
they said okay set it up they weren't
happy they wanted they wanted to stay on
windows systems so yeah you know we
didn't get to use some of the linux
stuff which might have made some things
easier except that
they just wanted one os to maintain
yeah
well i hope everybody has
that that good of an experience too we
had a great idea we were very fortunate
that's great does anybody have
questions about that or is like
experiencing this right now
rachel i i couldn't chat about that but
i don't want to monopolize anything like
we're going through it constantly and
we're in our
yeah so like
i feel the pain of where the question
has come from i've had it many places
and we're doing it now and like just
tomorrow i have a
architectural review board why are you
considering using r for pipelines into
just like those questions because i t
don't understand
right like how is a stats language
a thing to do stuff with data pipelines
so there's a lot of education
really people think of r
sorry if i say this but sorry not sorry
is 1985 r
well
it's moved on a little bit since i know
the language um
was great in the early 90s but they
think of it as that time frame it's not
this name anymore
yeah it sounds like it can be so
different across the board depending on
the industry that you're in or just the
company itself
javier rc how'd your hand raise too if
you want to jump in
yeah i was just going to add at
my last company this was like
a fairly regular conversation because
there was a cohort of kind of your
classical statisticians that were just
very comfortable doing their work in sas
and we got around that
um
i mean they still used sas to a certain
extent but having like
very
tailored walkthroughs of things you can
do
with r
um for like very specific teams so like
hey let's look at your workflow right
now and let's see how we could do this
in r
um that always seemed to really impress
especially when you kind of wrapped it
around our markdown or something to like
you know
very quickly and cleanly present your
data
um
so yeah i think just having these
one-on-one kind of smaller trainings
with these groups of sas users
uh like here here's how you do it in sas
let me show you how you could do it in r
i think that goes a long way
definitely
yeah we we've tried to get people into r
we did some of that stuff as well
um
it was just spotty whether people would
pick up on it with each of our ethies is
pretty independent in their programming
i mean we have those codes and stuff but
in terms of their assignments they can
choose what they want to use for what
they're doing
and it was hard to get people to dig in
to a new system because you know it's
easy to use what you know
but once we did
some people really took to it
on that topic too i see ethan you just
asked a question
as well about when you have people using
different tools do you want to jump in
yeah
so just want to ask that within your
team you mentioned that people use both
sides and uh you have a situation where
some people really enthused us and
people are really into uh how do you
manage
considering you're so code reviewing
each other because this is speaking from
my experience that i have called it's
reused not size without spss but we have
people who have
10 20 years of experience doing spss and
it
it's difficult to teach a lot of new
tricks so it's difficult to get people
to switch on to new stuff
yeah and uh
that would come down to who you choose
to do your code review
so we tried we tried we had a system
where you kind of rotate for everybody
but
if it's going to be some complicated
piece of r then you've got a they're
just a limited number of people are
going to do it same with same with sas i
mean we didn't have when people use sas
but we didn't have
a whole lot of people who were you know
super experts in sas
so it just came down to who did who's
going to be doing the code review there
again though it was always a it was a
great opportunity for discovery and for
people to see what was possible
so i think again about covid about the
we created the dashboard which i
wouldn't
i brag about how
great the functionality was and how it
looked um but we're not we weren't
expert enough to actually create a
dashboard that would load quickly so it
takes like 30 seconds to load and then
it's amazing um
but when people saw what was possible
it would get them excited and then if
you could show them how simple it was to
add a new graph or something
that could get them engaged as well
i see there was another anonymous
question too that was can joe and or
other people on the call too give an
example
or two of guidelines they have and far
as far as sorry just trying to read this
question as far as questions using chat
now that we are virtual
was that helpful
and if anyone has other contacts to add
to that question
please put it in the chat too
um
but i think it's just around
like guidelines that you mentioned for
like slacking people with questions now
that we're all virtual
right and
just if i can i'll try to remember what
our guidelines were but they were
essentially
first text somebody don't don't call
them don't do a voice call first text
them to see if they're available um
and then do a voice call and you call
them if they don't respond depending on
the urgency or not um and we'd use email
for
anything that needs to have a long-term
record you have to you do an email
because that's the only place that we
had the long-term records
but uh
to prefer for quick communication to use
a slack chat and or
whatever webex chat
and that was
to be used at any time and people should
at least acknowledge
at least respond when they've seen it so
you know there's somebody seen it
that was about the extent of our
guidance as i remember
yeah we we've been talking about it a
lot here at our studio
to like when you put us a message into a
channel that has a bunch of people like
everybody then starts to like try and
answer the question
instead of if it's just like targeted at
one person or the specific people that
need to see it
so we're working on on that now
that was that was another
mistake i made earlier in the pandemic
because when we switched he started
using webex chat the uh i said okay
there's a bunch of joke and i was like
okay well let's use this channel to get
work done
and then uh after a month i was like boy
that was a mistake we got to have a
channel we're talking to each other
we're all remote we gotta have some
social interaction here
yeah
angela i see you had asked a question in
the chat earlier
about using our studio cloud
but i'm curious to just hear some more
context of
of how you might use it
yeah so i should probably do a little
bit of an introduction um thanks for the
welcomingness to like whatever scale or
whatever amount of work we do with this
um
so i am the water resources planner for
penobscot indian nation and what is
central maine um
and so we've been using r for a long
time to do a variety of things but i
also work with a group tribal exchange
network group which we just deal with
try we help tribes all across the
country
doing environmental monitoring
help process their data
and the reason i ask about rstudio cloud
is for a variety of reasons anytime we
do training it's a real hassle to get
everybody
set up and there's inevitably problems
in any session um and then when people
go back frankly just what you guys were
talking about i t issues um it continues
to be such a pain and i just didn't know
if anybody had any experience um i
haven't looked into it enough whether
whether you can have data
posted locally and use rstudio to ingest
it or whether your data has to be online
i mean there's so many questions but i
really feel like it might be
a solution for a lot of
a lot of tribes mind you we have to have
internet connection which is not always
the case especially up in alaska but um
i guess i'm trying to figure out
how we can help train people but also
how we can help have people
something easier when they go home that
they don't have to call us up and go all
right this isn't working so any thoughts
would be great
i know
there you go
just say we didn't use our studio cloud
but um
we did use we've used a lot of online
trainings that are fairly self-contained
that have been been really useful just
you know our markdown stuff that and
with with available data sets that
people are just important and use on
their own systems
there's a lot of
webinars that i can share with you
angela about like getting started with
our studio cloud if you do want to try
it out too for other people that have
used it
for trainings
but i know that's like a huge benefit is
that
everybody has the environment already
set up with the packages that they need
so if it's someone
brand new to
to using r they don't kind of get stuck
in how do i even install this thing
yeah
that's what we're running into so if you
could send me stuff that would be great
rachel um that's really the biggest
problem is most of the folks not
everybody but most of the folks we are
training and working with haven't done
much coding um at all and so they
they're really starting off in the
beginning
um and and i love r my boss is actually
asked if maybe i would get r to make a
cup of coffee for me someday so i've
told them that that's my goal but um not
everybody has that has that level of
addiction i guess um so
so it's it's really can be can be like
almost like oh i don't want to use r
because i can't deal with the
complications and i'm interested i i
can't remember who it was that said i
think it was brian that said you could
um you have some hacks for for
installing it if you don't have
administrative approvals now that's the
first level and then
all the other like upgrading versions of
arts just can be a little bit daunting
so
thanks
yeah definitely thanks for the question
and and mike i might put you on the spot
here because it sounds like you have
experience doing that i see you but it's
brilliant for training
yeah um
so i've i've used it internally uh for
doing training with colleagues just as
you say
if you with even with the best will in
the world and a lot of
lead time
if you
if you rely on individuals installing
our and installing packages you're gonna
get a whole mess of different versions
different package versions different
package sets
guaranteed you'll spend half of the
training time ironing out you know why
this isn't working for a certain
individual because
who knows what you know whereas if you
if you pop open our studio cloud as
you're saying rachel like
you can set it up so that you guarantee
everyone's got the same
packages versions sets
ready to go and it just cuts out that
whole
now you know why are you seeing this not
working for you
i have to say that the
you know we had a few
um issues with it when i was um being a
classroom assistant in the teddy bears
training at our studio conference in
2020
i think that was
just you know that was almost a glitch
something in behind the scenes wasn't
working
just as it should on that occasion so it
was causing a little bit of glitchiness
um
but even then it's it's by far the
easiest way of just ensuring that
everyone's seeing the same things and
working off the same basis
awesome on that topic of training too i
see there was an anonymous question
uh what are a few starter packages or
skills for teams that are transitioning
languages
and i think joe this may even this might
be a bit on sas to r too
yeah we we uh
so
you know we had an epic group we had
whatever 15
number of people in buried but we had
good control over that environment and
so we had everybody installing the same
version
and we really pushed everyone to be
using uh tidy verse packages
as much as possible because i my big
concern with r is that there are so many
packages
if we've got people doing code audits
for each other i don't want to have
everyone have to learn
everyone else's idiosyncratic favorite
package
so we tried to have a lot of push toward
using the same set of packages and tidy
bursts is you know really nice and
comprehensive and such and we're into
the graphics a lot as well so a lot of
gg plot 2
code
and the
so i know that that's how we dealt with
the the the package of the the different
environment issue and again
it was just one group so we're mainly
just training that we worked worked with
the state health department to get them
trained in r2 and we kind of and they
helped us we did some sharing there
um
in terms of the transition from sas
though uh
i was never we never really had a
wonderful training solution we had we
just had people from the group put
together trainings and presented or find
trainings online and present those to
the group and again
it was it was here's an example of how
you do it in sas here's how you're doing
our
books that showed that sort of thing
um there's people going through examples
or the one-on-one code audit kind of
trainings that we did
no great solutions there from us
thanks joe there there's a few other um
anonymous questions too but again feel
free to jump in live into the
conversation if you want to just raise
your hand on zoom 2.
um
but one of the questions was how do you
manage a team
where there are different preferences
for languages
so we're we we stayed very organized in
our code and any work product we got
produced
had to have
code it was archived that went into a
repository you know and it got changed
that changes went to the repository so
we had a lot of uh controls so we could
always do what i call a data audit any
any work product that we produced over
the 18 years i was there you could take
that work product there'd be a an
identifier on it and you could track
that back to the code that produced that
data thing so if there's a problem with
it we could figure out what the problem
was or if you wanted to reproduce it you
could find the source code and you could
update that and use that code again
um
so we had
uh i've lost lost track of the question
i'm sorry
it was just around managing the team
where there's different preferences so
so right so so we sort of we built this
code library
that
had a foundation and sort of evolving
code for different functions that we
often did you know by the time i left
there there were there are thousands of
programs in this library but they're
tracked in a database and you could
search it you could find
useful code and it didn't really matter
if you used sas or r it was just to get
the work done i mean i i didn't really
care um i mean i really wanted the group
to move toward r i was kind of hoping
long term we could we could bounce off
the sas and maybe even get to like just
having a python r environment just to
get to
free programs that we could share with
other public health agencies and sort of
move the whole
public health informatics uh world
forward by being able to share code more
freely and not be limited by some of the
costs involved with sas um but i didn't
care if people used r or sas and we
created code that would allow people to
call r from sas or sas from r to try to
go back between the two and we had a lot
of model code for using the two of them
together to take advantage of some of
our graphics and some of the sas data
management um but we we didn't have
rules about it you know and we didn't
have like an fda breathing down our deck
our necks to say you have to conform to
this or that we were free to do whatever
we decided the standards would be
for sure
i know
something you're especially passionate
about is improving the public health
system and i'm curious if
there's ways that
we as a community can come together to
help
do that or what ideas you have for doing
this
there's there's some exciting stuff
going on in public health informatics
around
are around
just open source data sharing um
they're they're kind of one-off
initiatives for the most part but
they're folks who are
you know have
github sites where they're sharing their
code
um there are some communities of
practice there's one around uh they call
it syndromic surveillance but
essentially
uh looking at emergency department data
there's there's a national system
there's a lot of local systems that pull
in emergency department data and look at
it for
emergency uh emergencies that are
occurring or suddenly there's a bunch of
this disease or that disease we're
tracking covet there's all sorts of very
useful things you can do in emergency
department data to get a more real-time
picture of what's going on in your
community
and there's a community of practice
around that and the community of
practice
has a
group within it that's doing a lot of
sharing of
uh our code for analyzing this data and
some kind of standards for it there's a
there's a unified national platform that
has some of the data and they're sharing
our code for going up to that platform
and analyzing your locker of data from
that
and sessions about how to i mean it's
so i guess i see the opportunities
there's exciting stuff going on how this
community might help is
is just participating in a community of
practice they they work because people
engage in them and you guys have one
right here um so being engaged in a
community of practice supporting it
uh moving into uh getting very involved
and helping to move things forward lead
things you know take initiative and
really get engaged um i've got to say my
own career really comes
i am where i am now because of
communities with practice i started in
public health
you know back when when people wrote
with chisels and stones
but the
i evolved to where i am now which is i'm
i'm very involved nationally in a lot of
stuff because of communities with
practice by um it's sort of the duocracy
the people who do come into power you
get engaged you see what has to happen
you try to move it forward you work with
other people to make things happen
and you build things a lot of them fail
and some of them don't work but you
create a network that helps improve
things
that's great they have that community to
it
we've been trying to like start some
communities of help start some
communities of practice so for example
like for supply chain or
and i wonder how
like
how did they start that and then
move it forward so that like it's
actually progressing
um
and if it like did you
i don't know just just interested to
hear how it started and how you progress
um
i've been involved in trying to start
communities practice to just fizzled
and others that didn't
and you know some of them take some of
them did the ones the big one i think of
the fizzled is because it was sort of
attached to
a research
initiative that the cdc had but suddenly
the funding got pulled from it and so we
were sort of the
the
practice practice engine or the practice
appendage that was attached to this sort
of research community
research funded project and that went
away and so the appendage just sort of
faded uh and that will happen you know
every light is full of risks and you
invest and sometimes it doesn't pay off
um
it's gotta be around something that
people care enough to spend time doing
there's got to be some immediate payoff
to people and
i just in my experience i'm thinking
about the national public health
association and work groups that we've
had there
um
it's got to be something people care
about but you've got to have enough
you've got to have a couple people who
are spending a lot of their time
thinking about the community and how to
make the community work and how to
engage the community i mean and i think
rachel you probably have this role
within this group of
how do i
do something that these people care
about and bring them together so they
get value out of the times they're
willing to come next week to do this
again
and then relationships start to happen
because people start to meet and talk to
each other and side projects start to
build out of that and some of those fade
and some of those are successful there's
value that comes out of that and it can
grow
but you really have to have the gardener
you have to have the person cultivating
it or there's several people cultivated
really to create enough of a
payoff kind of socially and value in
terms of work
um that it moves forward and that only
happens because people take a risk of
investing their time
in it
somebody's got to gamble and put in that
effort
definitely that that's really helpful
joe
i i assume vin
you asked about this community as well
and and how you can find community of
practice would you want to jump in here
or you can read it if you want to add
yeah
i'm sorry i'm like in a busy area
no worries
so the question the question was um
joe i'm an epidemiologist in a local
health department using r
how can i find or join that community of
practice you mentioned that sharing code
for public health related data sure um
that would if you look up the uh the cdc
nssp
uh national syndromic surveillance
program i think it's called
um
you should be able to if you search for
that and syndromic surveillance you
should be able to find some community of
practice
um
jen
uh
my mike who works at the health
department i was at maybe you could help
get connected as well i think fresh
probably has a connection the
information for that community how to
get tied into that
awesome yeah jen if if you don't mind
sharing that in the chat that would be
helpful too or somebody maybe i already
did
you might also just uh if you look on
github for uh harold gill
h-a-r-o-l-d-g-i-l
um he's got he's got a github site he's
doing some really great stuff at
washington state with a group out there
um and he could probably help you get
plugged in or go to nato the the
national association of city and county
health officials
um and get involved in one of the work
groups there get involved in the epi
group or the informatics group
and you can get networked that way
and
start making things happen
n-a-c-c-h-o
awesome
thank you
stephanie i i see you also asked a great
question in the chat if you want to jump
in
hi this is stephanie right
yes that's stephanie
um
oh yeah so i was really interested in
how you were talking about show um
the code archive database you were
mentioning like like tracking everything
because i
like we've done a variety of things at
different places i've worked and none of
them have been like particularly user
friendly
yeah and uh
this is as user friendly as we've gotten
it still requires that each time that
you create a work product that you log
it into this database so that's that's
the trick making sure that people log it
so
when you start a work project um you go
to the database it creates a new id for
that work project you put in a title you
put in just some basic information about
the purpose of it it's not you know
there's only like
five fields you have to fill in
um and then you hit a button that
creates a folder for it it kind of does
some background ground setup to make
things easier for you and then you can
store your stuff within the structure
we've got on our network that
allows people to find things easily and
is based on that id
and then that id you're you're
responsible putting that id on any work
product or within the name of the files
that you create associated with this
uh
i'm not being really
clear about that but essentially the
core of it is there's an id that's
generated every time you do a work
product that id is the first thing in
all the file names associated with that
product
for the most part sometimes you have to
put it at the end because you want
people other people who aren't techies
to read it and it goes into a folder
that's in a structure where it makes it
easy to find all that information
that's kind of the core of our system
going um back to i know we were talking
a lot about like using different
languages and how you manage people
using different languages
but another question was
how do you handle the situation when
something breaks
and there isn't coverage across a
specific language like if somebody's out
on pto or something
um
we have enough people who have who know
assassin are that we've figured out
part of part of that goes back to the
documentation
for this because there should be a
record that explains what this program
well
you get the work product you can track
it back to this id to the program um we
have a standard header that goes in each
program that's supposed to explain
enough about that program
that people should be able to work their
way through it well enough um i really
encourages the lightweight to put it
that people put comments in their
program so that their other people can
read it you should in my group if you
write a program you should think about
writing a program to somebody else in
the group you're not writing a program
to get something done you're writing a
program yes to get something done but to
get it done in a way where somebody else
in the group can pick that up and
understand what you're doing so there's
got to be comments in your program
um
and then we've got enough people into
assassinar that we can figure it out for
the most part it's it's it's a risk it's
a challenge but uh but it hasn't been
too bad because we do require some
standards and documentation and again
that's a pain in the neck it takes time
and investment and people you gotta
enforce people doing that um but the
code helps with that as well part of the
code out is making sure that the
program's
clear enough and commented enough so
people can understand it
oh stephanie if if you want stephanie
you could send me an email or something
i can send you actually wrote up is kind
of our process for
doing that uh
the indexing of work products and stuff
like that
that would be great to maybe share
through our our linkedin group too it's
not
it's written for epi groups but yeah you
could share okay
i see mike you had asked has anyone
developed our snippets and distributed
them across a team
yeah we've asked do you try again siri
thought i was asking
that question
we've got uh
yeah we've got in addition to having
sort of the library of all our code
we've got some folders that have handy
code snippets and we just label them for
you know here's a good way to do this
here's a good way to do that
you know so people can go in there and
find useful approaches
and then the code itself is searchable
sorry are those snippets actually within
the rstudio ide or are they in a
separate document they're separate we're
just we just have you know a lan file
system with folders on it and one of the
folders is
useful
code and macros something something like
that and everybody knows you go there to
look for some tips
or to put ticks
i mean i i don't know if if people are
familiar with the snippets within the
rstudio ide but they're super cool
because you can set up template
frameworks where as you
pull in the snippet it jumps you to you
know what's the next thing that you need
to tailor for your own situation it's
essentially like a function but it's a
more of a kind of open code
those are super helpful mike i didn't
even know they existed until like six
months ago and i was shocked when i
found out about it but super helpful i
have all kinds of snippets for myself
and my team right
now they live in a a specific place
within your kind of um i think it's
within that data or something so it it
it's not terribly easy to share them
between people but if you're in an
organization where you can roll out
um
an installation or
you know
configurations like that then they're a
really helpful thing to know about
okay i'm gonna admit i didn't know that
either
so if you're in the i r studio ide
when you start typing a function name or
something you can use tab to auto
complete
but you basically give the
the little kind of template of code
has its own little name
and so if you hit tab
it will auto suggest one of the things
it will also suggest is either a
function or a snippet
and then if you choose the snippet then
if it's if it's like a gg plot framework
then it will say you know what's your
data what's the aesthetics and it kind
of just
guides you through filling in
the the right information
um
and so as i say it's it's almost like a
function
except that it's it's just helping you
it's a framework for writing your code
cool i see yeah
yan yen had asked a question to you mike
to share more on on what you did with
that if you don't mind sharing like
maybe some helpful links or resource you
use
for it um yeah i i i think tatsu has
just shared okay
code snippets um article which is great
um
i haven't used them in anger i think
that's you know i'd love to and i'd love
to share that more widely with
like you know folks i work with
um i think the problem that i have is
that um
sharing them out to other people
is
you know involves them having to save
the the right file in the right place
which is always problematic for anybody
it seems
but you can set up your own which is the
great thing
nice yeah i was talking about that
yesterday with someone around
like data products as well so like if
you had a template like example
our markdown or shiny up for something
for your company and making it available
for everyone to use
well that's that's what a package is for
right
well
i think like thinking about like having
it published somewhere that you could
just go and pull the example app
let me see if there are other
questions that i didn't see on slido yet
oh i see um
jen you had asked a question in the chat
too if you want to jump in
sure hey joe hey jen
it's good to see you
um
i was gonna ask what's the most
important traits that you look for when
you hire
like what questions do you ask to get
that information
um
[Music]
well so when i hire i'm not necessarily
hiring a data scientist i'm hiring an
epidemiologist
uh and and for an epidemiologist i want
somebody
who
well
for a worker i want somebody who's is
going to take initiative
um who's who's going to be able to to
work independently or get to a point
where they can work independently
um
who's got you know i don't know there's
not one they're going to have to have
good content knowledge
um
it's and yeah i would love to i would
love to be able to
have x-ray vision where i could see
they're kind of like you gen where
they've got this amazing data break and
they you know they grow to this stuff
and they can they understand you know
they just sort of start to intuitively
understand data structures and
and how to analyze stuff
um but that's that's not necessarily
essential
it's really more about
people who are gonna take initiative
um be able to work independently
and have some
have the right
knowledge at least i love people with
experience but usually we end up just
tying people out of school so it's at
least having sort of a basis of
knowledge
and and and well and it's public health
so they've got to have the love for
public health they've got to be invested
in what we're trying to get done they've
got to have the mission
how do you interview for that to know if
someone is going to like take the
initiative and
[Music]
we we um
we used a process called targeted
selection that i picked up years ago i
used to work for eli lilly the pharma
company um and they gave me this
training and this interview process
um
but you know you you lay out dimensions
that are important and then you have
several different teams and different
sessions
ask about those dimensions you have
several people asking about each
dimension in different
separately so you can combine you can
discuss afterwards
we make sure we ask for examples we try
to really
know people down to saying tell me a
specific situation
where you've been challenged with this
and what did you do and what was the
result as opposed to people saying
i'm really i really like doing this i'm
really good at that you know just
abstract talking trying to get people
down to talking about really a lot of
specifics um
and it's hard but it's it's i think
probably the biggest tool i've used for
making sure
seeing what people really have is ask
them for specific examples
and and asking them and and it's the
it's called the star format va so tell
me what's the situation or task you had
what did you do about it and what was
the result
that illustrates your ability to
whatever you're you're
interested in taking initiative or your
investment in the mission of public
health whatever it might be
thanks joe
i just want to check from the chat too
if i had missed your question feel free
to just raise your hand on on zoom too
um but
one question i had for you joe
um just being on a previous conversation
um
is we talked a lot a bit about
like technical skills are important but
a lot of it is also learning how to
partner with people yeah as well i was
wondering if you could chat a little bit
about that
yeah um
i've worked with people who have amazing
technical ability and just just super
great data brains but
at least at least in my field in
epidemiology
it's all about producing information
and it's about producing relevant
information so you've got to understand
the customer you've got to understand
their situation and
the better you understand where they're
coming from what they face day-to-day
the easier it is to add value to what
they're doing by bringing data to bear i
really i really see my group
in marion county as a support group as a
service group we're there to serve other
people other people have the they know
what their problems are
we need to
draw those problems out and understand
what those problems are kind of put them
into our data language and then be able
to apply data to those problems to get
back
to their their issues so
that that's that's the partnership
that's the understanding you have to be
really
the closer you are to the client the
better we've got some programs that are
really well funded we can have one epi
like spend most of their time on say hiv
we've got gentsman's half
she used to yeah
uh
we got somebody who spends half of their
time with hiv with an hiv program um so
they can sit with those people and
really understand their day-to-day work
and what the issues they face and
see the opportunities to bring data to
bear on that so it's around
really getting to know people um so then
you can translate their needs into
data needs pull the data and translate
it give it to them
and create systems where you know it's
not just answering individual questions
but it's creating systems where day to
day they can operate more effectively
because you've set a system up where
they get the information they need as
they need it each day
great thank you
well i get to ask you more questions
than if there aren't other questions
from the audience
but i'm curious about
your
recent like move to the found the
development foundation and how you made
that decision
after
like moving into your leadership role
with county
um
there's two things going on one one is
just the whole issue of equity and
racism
and
this being
just a really cool project to help try
to help public health move along the
pathway of
addressing racism and equity more more
squarely
a lot of interest in
integrating
more equity-based practices and how we
use data what we do with data
but within public health there's a lot
of discussion of that but we're still
trying to figure out what it is and this
is an opportunity to put a lot of focus
on figuring out what that what that
might look like
and it's been a tremendous learning i've
had a tremendous amount of learning over
the last several months working with
people who are much more in the racial
equity
work space and advocacy area to figure
out what it might mean
and just i always knew we need to be
closer to the community than we than we
were at marion county that the closer we
were to the community and again this is
getting back to understanding the
customer and understanding what the
needs are out there and being relevant
um the closer we are to them
more relevant we're going to be the more
valuable what we produce is going to be
and it's just been underscored in the
last several months about how important
it is to make the
affected communities the marginalized
communities partners in
figuring out what the questions are and
what the factors are you need to pull
together in the information the data to
identify to to bring to the surface the
issues like structural racism how that's
manifesting so you can put a spotlight
on that to try to bring about change
and let them help have them help frame
the results in a way that's going to
make that change move because they they
can frame the results in a really
salient
impactful way much more than i'm going
to be able to as a old white guy working
in an epi department
looking at data can do without their
engagement
um so that was a lot of
you know just just this opportunity to
be involved in something that i think is
really really important
um and it's and it's a platform where i
can be a lot more involved in some of
the national discussions that i was
involved with at marin county but now i
can have that's more central to what i
do
that's amazing joe
are there things that we can all do as a
community to as we like
you know bring things back to our own
our own companies
and think about the way
that we're all operating
there's yeah there's a there's a lot we
can do
um
it's really
somewhat so much of so much of what i'm
recognizing more and more is
um
the problem with race
the things that perpetuate racism and
structural racism
are
that we don't talk about it we ignore it
that we don't label it
um
so
and that's not that's not okay because
that allows it to continue if we really
want to change what's happening we need
to talk about
about white privilege and about how
like again i'm in public health so how a
lot of the differences we see in
statistics rather than just presenting
okay there's this difference in white
black in terms of health outcomes
frame that in the context of
we've got you know 400 years of history
where this group
has been oppressed in many ways we've
had not and not just you know before not
just
until the civil war but you know there's
redlining there's there's all sorts of
there's the implementation of like the
uh
uh the uh
whatever world war ii uh veterans the
veterans benefits and such like that
there's a lot of stuff that just really
left out these communities social
security when social security was
implemented it excluded
domestic workers and agricultural
workers which are we which were white
and black in all different colors but
most of them were different colors than
white and so the net effect of that
was a to oppress certain groups much
more than other groups
so bringing that to the surface when we
present results to frame it in more
context
where people can see
the structural racism the effects of
structural racism to push us toward
thinking about how to address those
issues you know um it's not just
uh a woman lives in a house that has a
lot of asthma triggers it's you know
there's a lot of dust there might be
cockroaches whatever we go and we can
intervene to improve that house or move
to a different house and that helps her
but we need to get back to why we have
people living in houses like that we
need to change the policies that are set
in that are allowing these inequities to
occur
and so it's trying to push back to more
root causes of
of the issues that we're trying to deal
with
hopefully and i know we're just at the
top of the hour but i'd love to keep
this conversation going if you have a
few more minutes joe
uh yes i do okay awesome
angela i see you had your hand raised
too if you want to weigh in
yeah i just wanted to say such great
conversation that you're having joe i
love to hear that
kind of
looking at the source of things we
one of the many things that we analyze
in our is our fish contaminant data so
penobscot nation has sustenance fishing
rights reserved in treaties
and as you can imagine
many sources of pollution do not allow
that to happen
even when fish
dams get taken out and fish come back up
from the ocean we're finding uh recent
studies that we've done we're finding
they're even more contaminated than
nonsense fish so
uh those conversations about what is
causing these problems are are so
critical so i just i just really wanted
to commend you for having that level of
conversation
yeah and i'm no expert in it i'm just
i'm just learning on this
and then again nobody is i mean you got
to give yourself some space and and
allow yourself to make mistakes but we
gotta try in this area and figure it out
take some exactly
exactly i think we have to get
comfortable with being uncomfortable
because it's not easy stuff and
and it's not going to be a simple
conversation so but commend you for
for having it it's really really
uncomfortable sometimes so thanks for
doing it
no it is for sure
and
and on that topic too of like getting
uncomfortable getting comfortable with
having these uncomfortable conversations
do you have maybe some suggestions for
us or tips of how we can
be approaches in our own organizations
or
[Music]
when we maybe see that some things yeah
yeah i mean the the thing is
you got to speak up
um
you got to give yourself a little
forgiveness for not always speaking up
but you got to take some risks and you
got to push it
and it's
i don't have the answers it's not an
easy thing
um
and i there's not a way to do it safely
really i mean there's always risk
involved
so i don't know i don't know you gotta
find
finding finding
i i guess when i look at the folks who
are really doing this a lot they've got
us a large group around them of allies
of folks who are always the wrong word
in that in that context but these are
people who
share the mission and can support each
other as they go forward because it's
not easy easy work and you need you need
people who are supporting you
one organization that i know of in the
data world is the ai inclusive
um
or from the i think the founder of our
ladies as well
but i'm curious if there's other
similar organizations too that we could
all share with each other i just put
that one into the chat
yeah um there's some really good work by
the mozilla foundation around equity
and
well community engagement that gets gets
into equity and i've spent the last
several months just going over this
whole area and doing a lot of research
in it so there's
a lot of organizations um
i don't ever think especially organized
but i might in a little while if you
ping me like in a couple weeks i might
have something that would be useful to
share
yeah that would that would be really
helpful joe
i
i just want to make sure that i've heard
everybody who had a question or wanted
to jump in too so i'll do another
check to see if there's anything i've
missed
i see chris is sharing a link in the
chat too thank you
i do want to
i think it's so important that we
continue to come to have conversations
like this as well and i know i kind of
just came at the very end of the session
here
so
i would love to to dive deeper into this
on future hangouts too
but thank you so much joe if people
want to connect with you or have other
questions what's the best way to connect
on linkedin or twitter
no it's like
email i'm an old guy
email is probably the best way
um
so i guess i guess i can share my email
if you get if people could try to make
clear in the subject line what it's
about like maybe it's connected to the
rstudio uh thing or something so i can
sort of segregate it off my other email
make sense of it
okay
great i will um i'll share that
with everyone too
but also
share some of the links that were
mentioned in the chat and tips
on our linkedin group
for the hangout
so if someone from the r studio team is
on and wants to share that link there
or i can go and grab it real quick
i'll put it into the chat
but every week after the hangouts i'll
try and share every link that was
mentioned or a few tips
from the featured leader
but thank you so much for joining us joe
and
sharing your experience with us
sure
happy to do it i'm glad you guys are out
there it's good to see groups getting
together learning from each other
and thank you all for for all the great
questions too have a great rest of the
day everyone
you